all right here's my grievance and and it
may seem trivial but it's actually
important in this era of gambling one
thing i've noticed in recent days
the injury report information that you
find on a team's official website is
often wrong
yesterday for example stefan diggs was
listed on the bill's website and the
chief's website as not practicing due to
an oblique injury he was he did practice
he practiced on a limited basis and
again it's not a huge issue but how do
you get that wrong and and it reminded
me of what happened last friday as we
were awaiting the final saints injury
report heading into the game against the
buccaneers in the divisional round the
saints had an injury report for friday
on their website that was grossly wrong
it showed michael thomas as out it
didn't list taysom hill at all and it
was clearly the friday report
of that week against the tampa bay
buccaneers and this is a critically
important piece of information for
someone who's going to be thinking about
what wagers they may or may not make and
i don't know how you get this wrong it
is the easiest thing you can imagine
that any pr department would put out the
name of the player the area of the
injury and whether he practiced fully on
a limited basis or not at all and i
think it's inexcusable to have these
mistakes chris and i keep noticing them
over and over again am i making too much
of it no well no you're not making too
much of it i mean from the team's aspect
that they don't care
you know i mean we know all those
reasons why they don't really want to
let anybody know what's going on and in
this status maybe they welcome the
mistake exactly oh sorry oops i i think
they did i do that i think there's very
little thought and like it's not like
there's not enough resources and thought
into it so one of those things mike i
think where you're laying it out right
here
like
sky judge it's the same type of thing
the nfl five years from now might have
to have an independent person in every
one of these buildings to go
no no i saw this guy he's getting
treatment on his calf muscle they put
you know whatever shoulder sprain that's
wrong it's his calf muscle and it's it's
questionable whether it'll play it's not
you know probable or something like that
they might have to do that for the
integrity of gambling and everything
like you're talking about
hey i don't disagree with that at all
and at least for now just make sure that
the information officially generated and
provided to the league is properly
reflected on your official website
that's the problem there's a disconnect
between what eventually is put out via
the league based on the information
provided by the teams and what the teams
directly put into their websites and to
me
i don't know look i understand typos
happen we have plenty of these typos but
this is important this is substantive
and people are relying upon this
information and i know last friday
people were like what the hell michael
thomas is out no he was in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports